bonjour à tous
donc puisqu'on est là pour pour se
raconter des petites histoires j'en ai
une à vous raconter un soir d'hiver je
rentre dans mon appartement des valises
plein les mains j'étais fatigué donc je
me passe dans mon canapé je dépose mes
valises super gt tranquille et puis
soudain je vois une punaise
ok on connaît on voit tous très bien ce
que c'est ok je respire un bon coup
et puis je tourne la tête j'en vois une
seconde
ok et là d'un coup elle se met à voler
donc je veux plaquent au sol 1ce c'est
une vraie histoire je veux plaquent au
sol
j'attends qu'elles se posent elles
finissent par se poser mais vous savez
les insectes ce types d'insectes c'est
le sait elles sont pas vraiment défini
de plan de vol à l'avance donc ça vole
un peu dans tous les sens ça fait un
bruit d'hélicoptère bref à la panique
bon donc il fallait que je trouve une
solution pour les évacuer là sachant pas
quoi faire et en ayant la phobie
j'ai décidé de prendre mon courage à
deux mains et d'aller frapper à la porte
du voisin
ouais attendez la suite
bon donc je le précise que je portais un
col roulé à un pantalon givet d'un pas
déterminé et
donc je frappe et là un homme un homme
ouvre la porte un peu peu étonnant avec
un marcel il était détendu
un dimanche soir et donc d'une voix un
peu frêle je lui dit bonsoir excusez moi
de vous déranger je suis un petit peu
embêté parce que j'ai deux pièces dans
mon appartement est ce que vous pourriez
m'aider les évacuer bon et là contre
toute attente il me répond eh bien
écoutez je vais voir ce que je peux
faire
mais ce soit il ya ma femme je pense
quand on s'était on s'était pas bien
compris sur le sur le sens d'évacuation
de punaises imaginez le flottement qui a
eu je suis resté un petit peu perplexe
et donc y faire la porte
j'étais toujours là il ferme la porte
j'entends mettre ses pantoufles pour
douillet quelques mots en italien
probablement à sa femme il ouvre la
porte d'un pas déterminé rang dans mon
appartement j'avais laissé la porte
ouverte sur le couloir et donc ils
évacuent les punaises aucun souci mon
problème était résolu je vais faire la
porte et puis j'avais enfin c'était bon
pour moi ok on sait donc tous se
retrouver dans une situation un petit
peu à un probable à vivre un discours de
sourds
parce que on peut interpréter un peu
tout suivant nos
en suivant nos expériences de vie
suivant le contexte et l'environnement
et puis suivant le langage corporel donc
je sais pas si vous le saviez mais il
existerait entre 3000 et 7000 langues et
dialectes dans le monde
vous imaginez je vous laisse imaginer
tous les quiproquos qui peut y avoir
avec nos langages on va lire on va lire
les expériences présente avec avec en
fait on va les enrichir avec nos
expériences tirées du passé
donc ça vous paraît peut-être un petit
peu abstrait mais en fait toutes ces
interprétations
elles vont reposer sur donc sur nos
expériences de vie sur notre vécu et
puis sur la déformation qu'on peut avoir
de la mémoire parce qu'en fait on
imagine avoir vécu telle ou telle
situation qui au fur et à mesure des
années ça se transforme et puis on va
interpréter la situation présente
suivant notre mémoire des formes et avec
l'analyse qu'on fait du présent donc je
vous laisse a aussi imaginé et puis la
perception qu'on peut avoir du futur
donc justement donc sur cette image qu
est ce que vous voyez moi je vois un
petit bonhomme avec un sourire et puis
un bandeau sur la tête
ça aussi c'est véridique je l' ai vu
toute ma plus tendre enfance pendant
bien longtemps et en fait vous l'avez
bien connu c'est le panneau attention
routes glissantes
donc lorsqu'on va communiquer on va
utiliser plusieurs manières entre autres
l'utilisation des mots donc là c'est
pareil
est ce que vous saviez qu'il existerait
entre 60 et 100 mille mots rien que pour
la langue française que pour la langue
française
et donc on va utiliser sim ces mots
suivants notre interprétation sur un
autre en fait on va les employés pour
leur donner une signification
particulière on est les rois pour ça et
donc on les utilise suivant nos
expériences de vie suivant la pertinence
qu'on veut leur donner suivant nos
émotions ça c'est très important parce
que ça va beaucoup lui l'impact que les
mots vont avoir sur nous mais maintenant
mettons nous à la place de celui qui va
recevoir cette information
on est tous dans cette situation et là
aussi on va l'interpréter suivant nos
émotions
suivant notre vécu et là on peut partir
un petit peu dans tous les sens bien
qu'on emploie les mêmes mots bon et si
finalement les mots n'étaient pas si
important comment on pourrait
communiquer les échanges se font aussi
par le corps vous vous rendez pas compte
mais en fait c'est ce qu'on appelle la
communication non verbale
elle se traduit par des gestes par
l'orientation du regard par la posture
est en fait par exemple ça nous est déjà
tout ça arrivait donc aller contre le
mur et de de croiser les pieds on est
bien on a l'impression d'être bien en
fait ça signifie il ya une petite
signification derrière tout ça il
semblerait qu'on soit soucieux du futur
un petit peu nerveux anxieux donc on se
ferme
un petit peu comme le croiser âge de
bras voyez c'est le même genre voilà on
se cale et on croise les on croise les
jambes ce type de posture qui est tout à
fait spontané naturel
en fait elle est l est mine de rien
importante parce que si on l'analyse ça
nous permet de rentrer en contact avec
l'autre et de comprendre notre
interlocuteur de savoir ce qu'il ressent
de comprendre son tempérament et de
pouvoir anticiper finalement tout s'est
tous les comportements qui vont pouvoir
se passer un second un second exemple
tiens quand vous quand vous serrer la
main de quelqu'un
bon il ya différentes façons de serrer
la main et entre autres vous aller
serrer la main donc avec la main droite
et probablement parfois accompagnés d'un
geste sur l'épaule ou sur le bras pour
rassurer votre interlocuteur donc il va
se sentir bien mais en fait ce qui sait
pas ce qui s'est passé que vous allez
l'amener avec vous et donc peut-être le
manipuler dès les premiers instants de
vos échanges vous ferai tant sur un an
vous y penserez vous verrez mail
avantages de la communication non
verbale
celle qui est maîtrisée ou non elle
permet vraiment de déceler et de
comprendre par exemple les non-dits où
les résistants ce changement comme on
l'a évoqué tout à l'heure ou pourquoi
pas même réorienter les négociations
face à un interlocuteur qui serait un
peu fermé en corrigeant apple tire nous
c'est très très utile pourquoi je
raconte tout ça parce que aujourd'hui on
a le pouvoir de comprendre on a le
pouvoir de saisir et de capter toutes
ces informations qui sont chez nous
partout dans toutes les situations
personnelles ou professionnelles
on a le pouvoir d' anticiper et d'éviter
les quiproquos en tout cas un maximum et
[Musique]
ces modes de communication is in ici
depuis notre plus tendre enfance ils se
sont adaptés au fur à mesure de
l'évolution de l'humanité est juste pour
eux dernière petite info
depuis je n'ai plus peur d'aller frapper
à la porte de mon voisin merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m